[Music]
suppose you love math and you had to
choose just one proof to show someone to
explain why it is the math is beautiful
something that can be appreciated by
anyone from a wide range of backgrounds
while still capturing the spirit of
progress and cleverness in math what
would you choose
well after I put out a video on
fineman's last lecture about why planets
orbit in ellipses published as a guest
video over on minute physics someone on
reddit asked about why the definition of
an ellipse given in that video the
classic two thumbtacks and a piece of
string construction is the same as the
definition involving slicing a cone well
my friend you've asked about one of my
all-time favorite proofs a lovely bit of
3d geometry which despite requiring
almost no background still captures the
spirit of mathematical inventiveness for
context spend to make sure we're all on
the same page there are at least three
main ways that you could define an
ellipse geometrically one is to say you
take a circle and you just stretch it
out in one dimension for example maybe
you consider all of the points as XY
coordinates and what you do is multiply
just the x coordinate by some special
factor for all the points another is the
classic two thumbtacks and a piece of
strange construction where you loop a
string around two thumbtacks stuck into
a piece of paper and pull it taut with a
pencil and then trace around keeping the
string taut the whole time what you're
drawing by doing this is the set of all
points so that the sum of the distances
from each pencil point to the two
thumbtack points stays constant those
two thumbtack points are each called a
focus of the ellipse and what we're
saying here is that this constant focal
some property can be used to define what
an ellipse even is and yet another way
to define an ellipse is to slice a cone
with a plane at an angle an angle that's
smaller than the slope of the cone
itself the curve of points where this
plane and the cone intersect forms an
ellipse which is why you'll often hear
ellipse is referred to as a conic
section now of course an ellipse is not
just one curve it's a family of curves
ranging from a perfect circle up to
something that's infinitely stretched
the specific shape of an ellipse is
typically quantified with a number
called its eccentricity
I sometimes just read in my head as
squish off' occation a circle has
eccentricities zero and the more
squished the ellipse is the closer its
eccentricity is to the number one for
example Earth's orbit has an
eccentricity 0.0167 very low squish off'
occation meaning it's really close to
just being a circle while Halley's Comet
has an orbit with eccentricities ear 0.9
671 very high squish off' occation in
the thumb tack definition of an ellipse
based on the constant sum of the
distances from each point to the two
foci this eccentricity is determined by
how far apart the two thumbtacks are
specifically it's the distance between
the foci divided by the length of the
longest axis of the ellipse for slicing
a cone the eccentricity is determined by
the slope of the plane that you used for
the slicing and you might justifiably
ask especially if you're a certain
reddit user why on earth should these
three definitions have anything to do
with each other I mean sure it kind of
makes sense that each should produce
some vaguely oval looking stretched out
loop but why should the family of curves
produce by these three totally different
methods be precisely the same shapes in
particular when I was younger I remember
feeling really surprised that slicing a
cone would produce such a symmetric
shape you might think that the part of
the intersection farther down would kind
of bulge out and produce a more lopsided
egg shape but nope the intersection
curve is an ellipse the same evidently
symmetric curve you'd get by just
stretching a circle or tracing around
two thumbtacks
but of course math is all about proofs
so how do you give an airtight
demonstration that these three families
of curves are actually the same
for example let's focus our attention on
just one of these equivalences namely
that slicing a cone will give us a curve
they could also be drawn using the
thumbtack construction what you need to
show here is that there exist two
thumbtack points somewhere inside that
slicing plane such that the sum of the
distances from any point of the
intersection curve to those two points
remains constant no matter where you are
on
at intersection curve I first saw the
trick to showing why this is true in
Paul Lockhart's magnificent book
measurement which I would highly
recommend to anyone young or old who
needs a reminder of the fact that math
is a form of art the stroke of genius
comes in the very first step which is to
introduce two spheres into this picture
one above the plane and one below it
each one of them sized just right so as
to be tangent to the cone along a circle
of points and tangent to the plane at
just a single point why you would think
to do this of all things is a tricky
question to answer and one that will
turn back to right now let's just say
that you have a particularly playful
mind that loves engaging with how
different geometric objects all fit
together but once these spheres are
sitting here I actually bet that you
could prove the target result yourself
here I'll help you step through it but
at any point if you feel inspired please
do pause and just try to carry on
without me first off these spheres have
introduced two special points inside the
curves the points where they're tangent
to the plane so a reasonable guess might
be that these two tangency points are
the focus points that means that you're
gonna want to draw lines from these foci
to some point along the ellipse and
ultimately the goal is to understand
what the sum of the distances of those
two lines is or at the very least to
understand why that sum doesn't depend
on where you are along the ellipse keep
in mind what makes these lines special
is that each one does not simply touch
one of the spheres it's actually tangent
to that sphere at the point where it
touches and in general for any math
problem you want to use the defining
features of all of the objects involved
another example here is what even
defines the spheres it's not just the
fact that they're tangent to the plane
but that they're also tangent to the
cone each one at some circle of tangency
points so you're gonna need to use those
two circles of tangency points in some
way but how exactly
well one thing you might do is just draw
a line straight from the top circle down
to the bottom one
along the cone and there's something
about doing this that feels vaguely
reminiscent of the constant some
thumbtack property and hence promising
you see it passes through the ellipse
and so by snipping that line at the
point where it crosses the ellipse you
can think of it as the sum of two line
segments each one hitting the same point
on the ellipse and you can do this
through various different points of the
ellipse depending on where you are
around the cone always getting two line
segments with a constant sum namely
whatever the straight-line distance from
the top circle to the bottom circle is
so you see what I mean about it being
vaguely analogous to the thumbtack
property in that every point of the
ellipse gives us two distances whose sum
is a constant granted these lengths are
not to the focal points they're to the
big in the little circle but maybe that
leads you to making the following
conjecture the distance from a given
point on this ellipse this intersection
curve straight down to the big circle is
you conjecture equal to the distance to
the point where that big sphere is
tangent to the plane our first proposed
focus point likewise perhaps the
distance from that point on the ellipse
to the small circle is equal to the
distance from that point to the second
proposed focus point where the small
sphere touches the plane so is that true
well yes here let's give a name to that
point that we have on the ellipse Q the
key is that the line from Q to the first
proposed focus is tangent to the big
sphere and the line from Q straight down
along the cone is also tangent to the
big sphere here let's look at a
different picture for some clarity if
you have multiple lines drawn from a
common point to a sphere all of which
are tangent to that sphere you can
probably see just from the symmetry of
the set up that all of these lines have
to have the same length and in fact I
encourage you to try proving this
yourself or to otherwise pause and
ponder on the proof that I've left on
the screen
but looking back at our cone slicing set
up your conjecture would be correct the
two lines extending from the point Q on
the ellipse tangent to the big sphere
have the same length
similarly the line from Q to the second
proposed focus point is tangent to the
little sphere as is the line from Q
straight up along the cone so those two
also have the same length and so the sum
of the distances from Q to the two
proposed focus points is the same as the
straight line distance from the little
circle down to the big circle along the
cone passing through Q and clearly that
does not depend on which point of the
ellipse you chose for Q bada-boom
bada-bing slicing the cone is the same
as the thumbtack construction since the
resulting curve has the constant focus
on property now this proof was first
found by jamming all jerk germinal Gemma
who cares dandelo n-- a guy named dan de
lijn in 1822 so these two spheres are
sometimes called dandling spheres you
can also use the same trick to show why
slicing a cylinder at an angle will give
you an ellipse and if you're comfortable
with the claim that projecting a shape
from one plane onto another tilted plane
has the effect of simply stretching out
that shape this also shows why the
definition of an ellipse as a stretched
circle is the same as the other two more
homework so why do I think that this
proof is such a good representative for
math itself that if you had to show just
one thing to explain to an on Matthews
iasts why you love the subject why this
would be a good candidate the obvious
reason is that it's substantive and
beautiful without requiring too much
background but more than that it
reflects a common feature of math that
sometimes there is no single most
fundamental way of defining something
that what matters more is showing
equivalences and even more than that the
proof itself involves one key moment of
creative construction adding the two
spheres while most of it leaves room for
a nice systematic and principled
approach and this kind of creative
construction is I think one of the most
thought-provoking aspects of
mathematical disco
and you might understandably ask where
such an idea comes from in fact talking
about this particular proof here's what
Paul Lockhart says in measurement how do
people come up with such ingenious
arguments it's the same as the way
people come up with madame bovary or
mona lisa i have no idea how it happens
I only know that when it happens to me I
feel very fortunate I agree but I do
think we can say at least a little
something more about this while it is
ingenious we can perhaps decompose how
someone who has immersed themselves in a
number of other geometry problems might
be particularly primed to think of
adding these specific spheres first a
common tactic in geometry is to relate
one length to another and in this
problem you know from the outset that
being able to relate these two lengths
to the foci to some other two lengths
especially ones that line up would be a
useful thing even though at the start
you don't even know where the focus
points are and even if it's not clear
exactly how you do that
throwing spheres into the picture isn't
all that crazy again if you've built up
a relationship with geometry through
practice you would be well acquainted
with how relating one length to another
happens all the time when circles and
spheres are in the picture because it
cuts straight to the defining feature of
what it even means to be a circle or a
sphere and this is obviously a very
specific example but the point I want to
make is that you can often view glimpses
of ingenious Ness not as inexplicable
miracles but as the residue of
experience and when you do the idea of
genius goes from being mesmerizing to
instead being actively inspirational
[Music]
you